bonsoir municipal 2014 sur TVfil 78 pour
tout savoir du scrutin la veille des
élections de mars et je reçois tout
d'abord ce soir Philippe Chevrier
bonsoir est tête de liste du
rassemblement bleu marine Rambouillet
également secrétaire départemental du
Front national dans les Yvelines vous
nous direz quelles sont vos ambitions
les ambitions de votre formation les
ambitions de votre liste aussi sur cette
commune de Rambouillet en plateau tout à
l'heure Étienne herassimus candidat
divivers droite à saint-ci l'école et
puis nous parlerons aussi de l'accord
modem UMP à Guill en courour de la
candidature de la gauche à Montini le
Bretonneux autour du Parti socialiste
Philippe Chevrier vous vous présentez
donc carambouillet sous cette bannière
du rassemblement bleu marine et vous le
dites vous-même vous partez de zéro le
Front national n'était pas présent en
2008 lors du précédent scrutin pourtant
les électeurs vous connaissent vous
étiez 3e au législative de 2012 sur la
10e circonscription avec 11 % sur la
ville de Rambouillet uniquement si on
regarde uniquement le score sur cette
commune 10,25 % vous avez totalisé un
peu plus de 10 % des des des voix c'est
l'ambition aussi pour les municipales
atteindre ce score voir le dépasser oui
c'est ça exactement si si on fait ce
score B ce sera très bien et si on fait
mieux bah écoutez çaa le champagne vous
pensez que c'est une base solide en tout
cas c'est 10 % vous AZ c'est une base
solide depuis les présidentiells le
Front national n cesser de de progresser
un peu partout donc on peut espérer qu'à
ambouillet il en est de même alors ce
qui change pas par rapport aux
législative c'est un scrutin purement
local cette fois-ci on n'est pas sur des
enjeux nationaux quelles sont vos
priorités pour cette ville de
Rambouillet dans un communiqué en
septembre dernier vous parliez sécurité
impôt identitaire embolitaine également
oui alors écoutez il y a de de de graves
dysfonctionnement à Rambouillet bon il
faut le dire
euh sans doute au début de ces
différents mandats Gérard lâcher c'est
très bien occupé deambouillet mais sur
la fin il a sans doute délégué à
d'autres personnes la gestion de la
ville et du coup c'est une ville qui est
un peu partie à Volot alors j'en veux
pour preuve la circulation automobile
qui est épouvantable il y a des moments
où on a des bouchons qui sont
inexplicables et et très longs le les
parkings qui n qui sont notoirement
insuffisant notamment à la gare or la
gare c'est très important parce que les
trains sont à 35 minutes du centre de
Paris et il y a beaucoup de monde qui
vient prendre ses trains non seulement à
de enouillet mais de toute la région
autour de rambbouillet et donc il y a
besoin de parking et
malheureusement le manque de parking est
criant pas seulement à la gare mais
aussi en centreville et ça c'est
extrêmement grave aussi pour les
commerces de proximité parce que les
commerces de proximité sont bien sûr en
concurrence avec les grandes surfaces à
rambbouillet vous avez Carrefour d'un
côté vous avez Leclerc de l'autre et
avec des parkings gratuit évidemment
donc évidemment ces commerces du
centre-ville peinent maintenant à à
faire face à cette concurrence et ils
disparaissent petit à petit donc ce le
risque que nous avons à rouiller c'est
que cette ville devienne une ville
d'ortoire et on sait ce qu'il a ce qu'il
advient des villes
d'ortoire donc effectivement ce que vous
avez dit est tout à fait juste mais en
plus donc il faudra euh faire un certain
nombre de choses concernant la famille
parce que la famille a été laissée de
côté à Rambouillet donc probablement des
tarifs pour les familles nombreuses pour
le sport pour la pour les transports
pour la
culture également aider les les familles
en difficulté je me suis aperçu aussi
que il y avait pas de service de bus le
dimanche or il y a des gens qui qui
voyagent le dimanche qui prennent le
train ou qui arrivent à Rambouillet par
le train ils n'ont pas de bus et
malheureusement les taxis manquent
également donc on voit des gens qui le
dimanche traînent leur valises dans les
rues de Rambouillet pour faire des
kilomètres c'est pas bien bon
normalement il faut un service minimum
bon vous parliez de l'identité rambolite
juste pour s'attarder sur ce point
l'identité rambolitaine pour vous c'est
quoi aujourd'hui ben écoutez c'est ce
que représente Rambouillet c'est une
ville
donc
présidentielle avec anciennement des
chasses présidentielles un
château voilà toute toute une comment
dire une architecture
et et un art de vivre qu'il faut
conserver et qui est en train petit à
petit de disparaître les rambolitains
que j'ai rencontré me disent voilà
Rambouillet n'est plus que nous avons
vécu quand nous étions jeunes euh il n'y
a pas non plus de vie nocturne à
Rambouillet euh à 10h du soir vous vous
promenez dans les dans les rues de
Rambouillet c'est c'est un peu Glo et du
coup euh euh vous savez ce qui arrive
dans ces cas-là c'est-à-dire que il y a
un sentiment d'insécurité qui se crée et
ce sentiment d'insécurité il est aussi
causé par un certain nombre d'événements
évidemment de fait divers donc il y a il
y a une personne qui s'est fait
poignarder euh auéré une autre à
Rambouillet donc et et il y a eu des
agressions dans le passé et cetera donc
les gens euh finissent par avoir peur
hein et donc là aussi il faudra faire un
effort de présence peut-être plus
visible plus efficace de la police
municipale un peu de vidéo surveillance
ENF bref euh voilà alors Gérard Larché
ne sera pas candidat ce n'est pas un
scoop hein il ne représentera pas l'UMP
après 30 ans passés en tant que premier
magistrat de cette commune mais il y
aura un candidat qui lui succédera c'est
Marc Robert je vous demandis peut-être ê
le regard que vous portez sur sa
candidature vous avez parlé déjà de
votre regard sur le bilan de l'équipe
Gérard Larcher sur les les
multiplications des candidature Marc
Robert il y aura aussi une liste divers
droite qui se présentera une liste
divers gauche probablement d'autres
aussi une liste Front de Gauche
également beaucoup de listes oui
beaucoup de listes bon mon regard sur
Marc Robert écoutez il n'était pas au
conseil municipal au dernier conseil
municipal mais c'est un siégé pendant 19
ans entre 89 et 2008 c'est un ami de
longue date de Gérard Larcher personne
enfin tout le monde le connaît tout le
monde connaît cette histoire plus
exactement et donc monsieur Larcher sera
sans doute sur la liste quand même de
même que Monsieur poisson donc il y aura
pas de grands changement si vous voulez
donc c'est c'est Monsieur Larché bis
quoi j'ai envie de dire donc il est
quand même il va être coresponsable du
bilan de de de la municipalité qui comme
je vous l'ai dit n'est pas exemplaire et
puis il va faire quand campagne alors il
est très peu connu moi je me je je l'ai
constaté à vrai dire c'est c'est pas
vraiment de sa faute je constate aussi
que dans les différentes communes les
conseillers municipaux ne sont pas
connus il y a que le maire qui est connu
éventuellement quelques maire adjoint
mais c'est surtout voilà le maire même
si c'est un scrutin de liste
effectivement on parle plus de la tête
de liste que l'ensemble des exement
exactement donc lui il n'est pas connu
il est donc il a il a cet handicap euh
et autant monsieur Larcher était un
homme de contact qui aimait bien contact
avec les gens serrer les mains et cetera
connaître l'histoire des familles et
cetera j'ai pas le sentiment de l'avoir
vu hein vous me demandez mon regard je
je je l'ai vu agir il est un peu distant
avec donc là vous vous dites il y a une
opportunité en plus avec cette
multiplication des listes juste pour
revenir à cette multiplication des
listes on pouvait lire aussi pendant un
temps une candidature probable de
Jacques Michel qui serait candidat à
rambouillè un ancien candidat du Front
National au législative en 97 c'est une
candidature que que vous craignez qui
pourrait l'électorat donc il y a 18 ans
hein à peu près donc il y a 18 ans
effectivement il s'est présenté sous les
couleurs du Front national il n'a pas
laissé un très bon souvenir que que que
autant que j'en sache dans dans dans
dans sa
prestation au conseil municipal depuis
il a quitter le Front national il s un
peu fâché avec le Front national comme
il a dû se fâcher d'ailleurs avec pas
mal de personnes euh il dit qu'il va
refaire une liste je ne sais pas sous
quelle étiquette je pense que c'est
divers droite ou quelque chose comme ça
euh
nous inquiète pas une candidature de
plus à droite franchement je je crains
de ne pas faire la majorité des voix
dans son immeuble mais à part ça ça ne
dépassera pas voilà vous êtes candidat
enbouillet responsable aussi de la
Fédération yvelinoise du Front national
combien de listes aujourd'hui sont
officiellement bouclé sur le sur
l'ensemble du département ben écoutez
j'ai sous les yeux je vois qu'il y en a
se voilà SEP liste est-ce que c'est dans
les objectifs que vous vous étiez fixé
euh bah écoutez boucler c'est formidable
je suis extrêmement contemp maintenant
cétait 0 en 2008 ah oui c'était Z0 en
absolument et nous en présentons donc
aujourd'hui 23 23 têtes de liste sur ces
23 il y en a donc 7 qui sont bouclés et
les autres sont plutôt bien partis elles
ont les autres ont ont dépassé la
moyenne si vous voulez Marine Le Pen qui
annonce environ 500 listes au niveau
national sur les 36000 communes c'est un
peu moins finalement que ce qui avait
été annoncé puisque elle souhaitait une
présence beaucoup plus massive qu'est-ce
qui explique ça justement c'est le fait
de difficulté de trouver non seulement
une tête de liste et puis ensuite
l'ensemble des candidats il faut au
minimum en général une trentaine de noms
et là c'est plus difficile c'est un
engagement beaucoup plus fort que d'être
adhérent les gens peuvent être adhérents
d'un parti politique sans que leurs
voisins le sachent par contre quand ils
se mettent sur une liste municipale
c'est clair que au vu et au-dessus de
tout le monde dans leur propre commune
dans leur propres immeuble tout le monde
va savoir qu'ils sont candidats Front
national c'est une étape majeure enfin
un engagement très fort parce qu'on
parle souvent de la dédiabolisation du
Front national c'est pas encore acté si
si on le on le sent enfin l'accueil
qu'on a sur les marchés n'a plus rien à
voir avec ce que ce qu'il était il y a
15 ans pas de là à franchir le pas et à
s'engager sur une liste vous savez je
crois que même à gauche hein c'est
difficile hein je j'en parlais
d'ailleurs avec le candidat ex Parti
socialiste là de de de Rambouillet
Jean-Luc trotigon qui présente
surétiquette centre div il a autant de
difficultés que moi et je pense un peu
plus regardez par exemple la Rambouillet
j'ai fait ma liste pendant les vacances
de Noël en 15 jours donc ouais c'est
quand même pas sur une longue période
donc c'est pas extrêmement long c'est
pas extrêmement difficile ça m'a demandé
de l'engagement personnel c'est sûr mais
ce n'est pas impossible c'est c'est
c'est franchement beaucoup plus facile
que je ne l'aurais pensé au début et si
j'avais pensé d'ailleurs que c'était
aussi facile on aurait sans doute
beaucoup plus de tête de liste
aujourd'hui dans les ivelines Montini
hloncour Versailles les clés sous bois
voici quelquesunes des villes où il y
aura des des candidats Front National a
priori l'objectif est le même partout
dépasser les 10 % 10 % c'est une base
raisonable voilà voilà c'est une base
raisonnable alors aujourd'hui pour vous
donner un peu d'information on a on a
justement puisque vous parliez de la
difficulté de de venir sur ces listes on
a aujourd'hui près de 600 personnes qui
se sont mises sur ces listes voyez qui
sont colistiers frond national dans les
ivelines donc c'est c'est énorme c'est
c'est c'est totalement inespéré quoi
juste pour parler de des résultats que
vous attendez sur ces différentes listes
est-ce qu'il y a tout de même des
communes où ce sera plus difficile je
pense à versaill par exemple versaill
votre candidat est peut-être handicapé
par la présence d'une liste issue de la
manif pour tous le Front National a
souvent affirmé son refus du du mariage
homosexuel on l'a en revanche pas
forcément beaucoup entendu il y a un
collectif qui s'est monté qui a pris la
parole et qui continue encore
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça ça peut
handicaper vos candidats on verra dans
les urnes on verra on verra là je
franchement c'est beaucoup trop T pour
le dire je crois que ce sera intéressant
de regarder les résultats justement mais
la Manis pour tous c'est pas quelque
chose qui qui va gérer une ville enfin
je sa pas un projet pour gérer une ville
c'est pas non plus un projet pour gérer
une nation le Front national la défense
de la famille plus globalement au-delà
de de de de marageexuel ça fait partie
de votre programme mais de sur cette
partiel où on entendait avant beaucoup
le Front national on l'a entendu
beaucoup moins oh mettez-vous à l'écoute
mettez-vous à
l'écoutes Contin àer nous sommes à
toutes ces manifestation nous nous nous
exprimons quand quand on nous demande de
le faire euh moi je remarque d'ailleurs
que je suis candidat quand même depuis 9
mois je n'ai eu aucune interview sur
aucun journal local alors que vous
parliez de Marc Robert par exemple j'ai
vu deux fois son apparition sur le
journal local voilà bon il y a un pare
pas de PO de mesure sur cette antenne il
s'est exprimé de la même manière que
vous c'est vrai bon c'est vrai qu' qu'on
part de zéro et que c'est un petit peu
plus difficile pour nous de nous faire
connaître mais je constate quand même
que voilà malgré des communiqués de
presse que j'ai envoyé à la presse et
cetera jusqu'à aujourd'hui voilà les
informations se relayent toujours de de
la même façon soyez à l'écoute aussi
vous le savez tous les candidats ici sur
cette antenne peuvent s'exprimer merci
Philippe Chevrier d'être venu Surate
merci d'être venu commenter votre
candidature pardon à Rambouillet et vos
différentes listes pardon sur les
ivelines le temps de reprendre mon
souffle on va passer au brève et puis un
autre candidat va venir sur ce plateau
merci
en bref tout d'abord l'alliance du MoDem
et de l'umpa Guill cour Jean-Louis Caria
reçoit rejoint Ladislas scoura 2ème sur
la liste centriste en 2008 il avait dans
un premier temps reconnu partir de loin
n'ayant d'ailleurs pas eu la possibilité
de siéger dans l'opposition au regard
des résultats de sa formation
aujourd'hui il sera donc au côté de l'un
des plus jeunes candidats de ce scrutin
dans les ivelines à 25 ans Ladislas
scoura entend surtout capitaliser pour
la venir et rassembler l'opposition
assez peu implantée ces dernières années
dans la ville de guillancour à Montini
le bretogneux vivient Gasque pour le PS
annoncé le rassemblement de la gauche
l'accord esttacté avec Europe Écologie
Les Verts le PRG les discussions qui se
continuent et qui se poursuivent avec le
Parti communiste français trois listes
devrai donc se disputer la mairie en
mars l'alliance de la gauche face à
l'alliance de la droite et face au Front
national à noté que Vivien Gasque
tiendra un 6e atelier sur l'avenir de la
ville le 11 février à la Maison de
Quartier Louis Jouvet l'avenir de
l'ancien collège Berkson sera abordé à
cette occasion le candidat souhaite en
faire une cité des cultures de la
musique et du théâtre et nous revenons à
Rambouillet où une nouvelle liste a été
officialisée une nouvelle liste annoncée
une liste divers droite qui vient
concurrencer Marc Robert successeur
désigné de Gérard Larcher nous l'avons
rencontré sur le marché il nous explique
sa démarche au micro de Michel Jarry ben
moi je suis un ancien offic de
gendarmerie donc je suis ensuite passé
dans le civil il y a y a quelques années
en tant que directeur commercial dans
une entreprise dembouillé et donc je me
suis beaucoup engagé dans le monde
associatif notamment pour la défense du
du régime de l'auto-entrepreneur depuis
depuis 4 ans et avec un groupe d'amis et
de de rambolittin on a décidé de monter
il y a quelques semaines cette cette
liste donc d'union citoyenne positionné
à droite pour essayer de de de réveiller
la ville redonner du dynamisme à cette à
cette très belle ville de d'île-defance
qui qui pour nous dor voilà alors on
vient effectivement apporter une
nouvelle jeunesse on vient apporter des
idées on vient apporter de la modernité
de l'innovation
on vient apporter aussi des comparaisons
avec ce qui peut se faire ailleurs pour
essayer de de faire changer les choses
que ce soit au niveau de l'attractivité
pour les entreprises au niveau de la
famille on vient apporter des idées
aussi sur la la gestion des finances
c'est un point très très important de
cette campagne puis qu'on a en tant que
dirigeant cadre en entreprise des
compétences assez marquées en finance en
gestion et on pense qu'on peut les
apporter à la à la ville pour redresser
les impôts et abaisser cette dette qui
qui est aujourd'hui très importante
alors notre liste elle est composée de
de citoyens vraiment issus de la soci
socié civile de cadres de dirigeants
d'entreprise d'entrepreneurs d'étudiants
de mère au foyer de retraités d'anciens
fonctionnaires d'anciens militair on a
vraiment de toutes les couches de la
population socio-pressionnelle de tous
les quartiers de tous les âges on a
voulu faire un panage assez complet et
cette cette démarche finalement
citoyenne elle plaît beaucoup et elle
fait que on arrive très rapidement à
boucler cette liste et apporter une
vision assez globale de tous les
quartiers de la
ville
second invité de cette édition de
municipal 2014 étienassimus bonsoir vous
êtes candidat tête de liste réussir à
saincir l'école une liste divers droite
vous êtes vous-même élu d'opposition udi
mais vous n'avez pas l'investiture de
l'UDI l'UDI avec l'UMP a préféré
investir le maire sortant Bernard Debain
est-ce que c'est un regret pour vous de
ne pas avoir cette étiquette udi c'est
pas vraiment un regret il y a eu un peu
de suspense effectivement autour de
cette investiture
udi finalement attribué à Bernard Debin
d'tact sur le fond ça ne change rien à
la démarche que j'anime sur saint-cire
avec mes colistier une démarche qui se
veut surtout une démarche d'alternative
crédiible avec un positionnement
politique clair de de centre et de
droite pas fâché avec l'UDI non non non
il y a pas de raison de l'être et avec
surtout à la clé un projet je dirais
enfin un projet pour l'avenir pour sa-ir
ce qui manque quand même cruellement à
l'heure actuelle on va évoquer ce ce
projet juste pour préciser que vous êtes
tout de même engagé dans un vrai bras
faire avec le maire sortant plusieurs
élus de sa majorité ont démissionné pour
vous rejoindre Bernard Debin c'est votre
principal adversaire dans cette campagne
avant même la liste de gauche j'irais
pas jusque- là mais il est vrai qu'il y
a eu un certain nombre de départs de sa
majorité qui ne date pas d'ailleurs je
le précise de 2013 he quand on regarde
au fil du temps il est assez frappant de
voir que depuis le début de la mandature
he depuis 2008 il y a une succession de
départ qui se sont fait 13 au total
j'insiste vim mê d'ailleurs parce que
vous étiez sur la liste de Bernard en
2008 2 ans après décider de de partir
dans l'opposition pourquoi vous aviez
fait ce ce choix bien écoutez il faut se
remettre un petit peu dans le dans le
contexte de l'époque j'étais
effectivement en 2008 sur la liste de
Bernard Debin il faut se remettre aussi
en tête la période un peu agitée qui
avait précédé l'arrivée de Bernard Debin
et il y avait une aspiration je dirais à
de la part de la population à une vie
politique une vie locale plus sereine
plus calme et Bernard Debain dans un
premier temps je dirais a bien donné le
change une image un peu père de famille
qui passait bien et qui semblait
correspondre à l'attente de de la
population j'avoue que moi en 2008
j'étais tout à fait dans dans ce regard
dans cette optique et j'étais allé sur
sa liste sans sans hésiter et puis à
l'usage au fil du temps il est quand
même apparu assez rapidement un certain
nombre de difficultés de lacune à la
fois dans l'animation dans le pilotage
de l'équipe et puis surtout dans la
détermination ou la définition d'un vrai
projet pour la ville et au-delà donc
d'un CAP à donner et au bout d'un peu
moins de 2 ans à la fin toute fin 2009
j'ai préféré avec un certain nombre de
colistiers quitter la majorité sachant
que certains avaient déjà effectué cette
démarche un peu avant donc au fil du
temps 13 départs de de la majorité qui
sont quand même symptommatiques d'une
vraie difficulté de fonctionnement et le
fait que cette ancienne majorité se se
cristallise aujourd'hui autour de votre
candidature ça veut dire aussi qu'il va
falloir aux yeux des habitants de Saint-
cire assumer une partie du bilan du mer
sortant écoutez moi je pense que nous
avons joué notre
rôle très clairement depuis 4 ans enfin
plus de 4 ans maintenant avec il compris
avec les élus qui nous ont rejoint qui
est un rôle constructif constructif
pardon il s'agit pas d'être dans
l'opposition ou dans la critique
systématique nous sommes là pour
construire pas pour détruire quand nous
estimons que les choses ne vont pas nous
le disons nous en privons pas et je
crois que les élus qui m'ont rejoint
encore en fin d'année dernière en
octobre et en novembre ont tiré les
mêmes conclusions et on rejoint pour la
même raison finalement la gauche au
précédent scrutin totalisé 35 % environ
des des voix avec cette division de la
droite vous ne craignez pas que il soit
difficile de deer non euh très
franchement je ne crois pas à un
basculement de la ville à gauche il va y
avoir un premier tour qui va permettre
de de se compter mais et justement vous
dites se compter ça veut dire des
alliances probables au deuxème tour
est-ce que vous discutez déjà par
exemple il y a une liste aussi menée par
Gaetane des jardins pour le moment je je
ne discute pas le le premier tour va
intervenir avec un certain nombre de
listes 5 au total don celle de de
Gaetane des jardins catalogué sans
étiquette ce qui au passage est un peu
surprenant là je me permets un mot de
commentaire voilà quelqu'un qui a quand
même été je le rappelle 5 ans premierè
adjoint Bernard Lavau maire RPR UDF
l'époque qui PhIP la Philippe Lavau par
phipe la et puis également donc
quelqu'un qui était premier adjoint au
maire qui a été également encarté si je
puis dire UMP sur une période longue
jusqu'à une période très récente
d'ailleurs et puis qui pour finir a
également été candidate aux élections
cantonales notamment sous une étiquette
divers droite et qui aujourd'hui se
présente et se définit comme sans
étiquette je ne trouve personnellement
pas cela très cohérent et peut-être pas
très honnête vis-vis des saint-syriens
en tout cas on F pas d'alliance avec
elle pour le deè tour pr au premier tour
certainement pas le deuxème tour sera
une une autre affaire nous aurons
l'occasion d'en d'en parler encore une
fois on verra si elle a apprécié vos
déclarations de ce soir pour ensuite
faire une alliance en tout cas vos
priorités pour la ville le transport on
peut peut-être en parler toutême parce
que c'est un souci majeur sur cette
commune de saint-cire l'école et c'est
pas propre à ces dernières années bien
sûr une difficulté effectivement très
importante de de circulation sur
saint-sire qui appelle un traitement je
crois assez enfin même très volontariste
au moyen d'un dialogue avec ave
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs les
communes voisines un certain nombre de
partenaires je pense en particulier à la
communauté d'agglomération de Versailles
Grand Parc au conseil général au conseil
régional car il est clair qu'il faudra
trouver des solutions en terme de
transport en commun c'est certain je
pense à la à la Tangentielle mais
également en terme de circulation
routière il va falloir se poser très
sérieusement la question du
contournement de saint-cire et de la
réponse à y apporter en liaison bien sûr
avec les partenaires que j'ai cité la
commune ne peut pas c'est évident faire
tout toute seule sur ce sujet vous avez
mentionné la la tengence je rappelle
cette tangentiel ouest c'est la ligne de
train train qui reliera Saint-Germain ha
r à saint-ir l'école rerc ça c'est un
plus pour le développement de la ville
effectivement ce
projetv sincè l'école c'est beaucoup
développé en terme d'urbanisme
aujourd'hui vous pensez qu'il faut
encore construire il y a d'autres zones
d'activité qui vont se développer
crenard par l'urbanisme enfin la
maîtrise de l'urbanisme est un vrai
sujet une vraie préoccupation que l'on
constate chez les saint-syriens
lorsqu'on parle avec eux très rapidement
c'est un sujet qui arrive sur la table
c'est une préoccupation je crois que le
la réticence n'est pas tellement dans la
perspective de voir de des logement se
construire de toute façon il y a un
besoin qu'il faut satisfaire et là je
crois qu'il y a nécessité de construire
de densifier en revanche ce sont les
conditions dans lesquels cette
densification et cette urbanisation
s'opère alors le quartier de la
zincrenard est tout à fait symptomatique
de cette interrogation de cette
inquiétude même dans la population
saint-syrienne puisque pour dire les
choses clairement je considère
qu'aujourd'hui ce projet n'a pas été é
suffisamment travaillé suffisamment
abouti et qu'il faudra là aussi le
renégocier le retravailler en
particulier dans ces aspects de
circulation de dessert tel qu'il est
conçu aujourd'hui il est extrêmement
enclavé et il sera si on le laisse en
l'état une source de difficulté de
circulation supplémentaire c'est
inexorable donc il faut remédier à cela
un Moot encore concernant vos priorités
on a parlé urbanisme on a parlé
transport quels sont les les dossiers
que vous allez mettre en avant dans ce
premier tour alors outre urbanisme et
transport je mettrai l'accent sur le
développement économique donc je fais un
petit peu ma marque de fabrique avec
l'équip de réussir que j'anime car c'est
vraiment le préalable ça dorait même
être le premier à citer le préalable à
toute action puisque c'est le
développement économique qui conditionne
le dynamisme d'une ville bien sûr qui
conditionne le dynamisme mais aussi qu'
a des retombées je pense par exemple en
terme d'emploi et là il faudra
effectivement agir dans deux directions
une première direction impérative qui
est la revitalisation du commerce de
centr-eville là aussi les échange avec
les commerçants montre quand même un
état je dirais de souffrance de leur
part extrêmement préoccupant il faut
faut vraiment agir de façon très
volontaire sur le commerce de
centr-eville en agissant par exemple sur
le stationnement on a beaucoup de
retours sur les difficultés de
stationnement et le incidence sur les
l'activité des commerçants donc ça c'est
vraiment un premier axe incontournable
et puis à côté de cette revitalisation
du commerce de centr-eville une action
forte en matière d'activité sur toutes
les opportunités foncières qui vont se
présenter dans les années à venir on a
parlé de la zacrenard il y aura un volet
activité on a parlé du volet logement du
volet résidentiel volet activité à
travailler de très près et puis
peut-être un petit peu plus loin à
l'avenir mais nous évoquions la
Tangentielle il y aura un nœud euh
intermodale autour de la gare de
saint-cire qui sera extrêmement
intéressant vous l'avez dit en terme de
dessert de circulation mais qui fournira
sans doute aussi des opportunités en
terme d'activité économique il faudra y
travailler aussi très rapidement pour
conclure comment se passe la campagne
actuellement elle est plutôt tendue il
me semble entre les différents candidats
il y a juste terminer par ça mais il me
semble qu'il y a quelques échanges via
les réseaux sociaux qui vous concernent
notamment avec
vient ass sont é il y a quelques
quelques moments de de tension mais
enfin je crois qu'il faut relativiser
c'est un peu je dirais la la tradition
saint-yrienne si on remonte quelques
années en arrière on s'aperçoit que le
débat est parfois un peu animé à mon
sens et en tout cas de ma part il reste
correct respectueux bien entendu des
adversaires moi j'ai pour habitude de
dire que j'ai des adversaire mais pas
d'ennemis en politique et je m'y tiens
donc la campagne est peut-être un peu
tendue par moment mais elle se poursuit
à mon sens dans des conditions
acceptables les téléspectateurs pourront
juger prochainement puisque nous
organiserons un débat sur saint-cire
l'école et tous les candidats sont bien
évidemment convié merci Ettien d'être
venu sur ce plateau c'est la fin de ce
numéro de municipal 2014 rendez-vous
mardi prochain 18h30 toujours en direct
et puis je vous le disais c'est dès la
semaine prochaine que sur TVfil elle
débutera une série de débats et sur une
quinzaine de communes des Yvelines
chaque mardi chaque jeudi à 20h d'une
demi-heure à 1hure avec les candidats de
vos communes premières villes sur
lesquelles nous nous arrêterons boî
coignère et voisin le Bretonneux je vous
souhaite une excellente
soirée